fishing out his front door like he has
for the last 40 years
amerin niyomong lives in a community of
houses built on stilts
lining the edge of bangkok's busiest
canal
while the fishing might be convenient
the steady increase of commuter boats
rushing by
has become unbearable he says but
there's some relief
on the way a switch to electric boats
electric boats will generate less noise
and won't bother people so much
bangkok was once described as the venice
of the east
and many of the 10 million people here
still use its waterways to get around
and the boats used to carry them are
noisy big polluters putting toxins in
the water and into the air
so the city government has launched a
quieter and greener alternative a
three-month electric boat pilot program
right in the center of the capitol eight
boats to start and so far
they're carrying a thousand passengers a
day so while it takes four hours at the
pier to fully charge the batteries
to run the twin engines for the boat
these solar panels provide the power
for the instruments and the lights on
the vessel
the biggest challenge is changing
people's minds we have to encourage them
to switch from private vehicles to
public transportation
boats are a good option because of the
heavy street traffic so the introduction
of electric boats
can help both congestion and reduce
pollution the boats and most of the
components are manufactured
here in thailand only the motors and the
batteries are imported
there's hope that the indigenous
industry will expand so one day
the vessels will be 100 thai
i think ev is a kind of the initiate
the next step to encourage
people or even the government itself
to look more seriously think about
having the ev or electric vehicles
because
it is the next generation for
for the environmental friendly public
transportation
so while the government hopes that the
program is successful and that the
fossil fuel
powered boats are on the way out omran
could be getting some good news
his canal is set to be the next phase
for the electric boats
and that will allow him to fish in peace
and relative quiet
scott heidler al jazeera bangkok